so your latest film created equal how
many people would show up on set every
day depending on the day and courthouse
scenes lots and lots smaller scenes more
cruel stunt people but if you're
directing you're in charge of a lot of
folks 30 40 50 sometimes 100 more doing
a big feature film PFT 100 you have to
translate your vision to everybody from
the Teamsters to the actors to the first
and second ad the DP sound would robe
props costume because for me I have some
very paranoid director I go through my
sets at least 5 to 7 times every set i
block my DP everybody comes with me they
knows and I have my assistant right my
shot list so every angle every shot
every setup my entire staff and crew
have it a week before I shoot there's no
drama no mystery you come to the set
cast comes in another blocking we may
make some adjustments but they know
everything so that when we're there we
work it's not figuring things out
rehearsals give you room to for the
actors that don't feel comfortable
sitting here if I sit over here fine
that's not a problem but we don't say oh
wait a minute instead of waiting for the
Sun to shine wait for the Sun to set
they don't happen
it makes you didn't make your day you
just have to be it's planning director
is there in charge of three things not
two things to create a process if the
translates your vision to everybody but
the second thing is that their managers
the managers of three things time people
my it's mathematics you have 12 hours in
a day that you can work so number of
scenes they're broken down to two setups
each set up you have a certain number of
minutes to make your day accurate comes
in on prepared and that's a big problem
so work as a team a collaborative effort
understand their obligations and
responsibilities
you